hi I'm Francesca and I've got a great  Lantern project for you today it's made  out of lovers and I'll show you how you  can do it yourself you will need an old  CD the glue gun a tea light and about  150 models of any color you like begin  by gluing marbles all the way around the  edge of the city make sure to put glue  on the sides of the marble - so the  whole thing is stable the first row  should look something like this glue the  next row on top of the first hot glue  cools and happens very quickly so take  care and pacing the madness you can  already get an idea of how it will look  in the end glue as many roads as you  like I've used seven rows of Marvis  finished now I'll just have to remove  excess glue drop in a candle and the  lantern is good to you nice light isn't  it if you like you can also use multi  colored marbles which will make super  great light effect  [Music]